le robert son marché sa mairie et ses
sargasses quartier punta les rues
d'énormes tracteur tentent de draguer la
portion de mer qui se trouve à proximité
des habitations
sous le regard dépité dérivant de jamais
vraiment là on peut même pas profiter de
l'extérieur on prenait bien avec les en
plus quand on est à l'intérieur on a des
problèmes avec nos électroménager
générateur congélateur les administrés
se plainent quotidiennement auprès de
leur mère
impuissant le premier magistrat de la
commune dresse un tableau inquiétant de
la situation
économiquement c'est pouvoir évaluer
mais les gens peu de nos clients ne
viennent plus la consommation les
produits que nous avons fait
vous avez dû vous à dire à présent sa
[Musique]
globalité
sur le front de mer la plupart des
restaurants sont déserts dans cet
établissement qui affichait complet
avant l'arrivée des algues la
propriétaire raconte ses déboires à
cause des odeurs de sargasses
c'est des journées et des soirées quinze
jours avec zéro couvert donc ça veut
dire que j'ai un établissement de 30
couverts
je perds une moyenne de 60% parce que je
ne dis pas que je fais le plein mais je
fais une moyenne de 12 couverts jour
aujourd'hui je fais 0 couverts jour
depuis un moment au bord de mer
la plupart des pêcheurs rentrent leurs
embarcations plus tôt que prévu et sur
les étals le poisson se fait rare
la pêche est devenue compliquée la photo
est telle que je la mets raffinés
nettement el maghrabi et la capuche et
montre avec l'appui par rapport à faire
parce que hincapie en matière des
moments monte malgré mon temps mais à la
montée à 6 les largades et c'est la
fille willow à réussir sa bouche et les
moteurs difficile d'évaluer l'ampleur
des dégâts pour l'ensemble des activités
de la commune le maire évoque la
responsabilité de l'état en attendant
les recettes actuelles des commerçants
laisse entrevoir des fins de mois
difficiles
[Musique]